words are coming out of my mouth just
vendrick has spreadsheets and Chris Sims
is holding a football oh it's cable as
usual that's the three of us in a
nutshell we got our cups Sims and left
go sustainable yep friendly I peed in
mind today to pass my drug test well
done and Josh and I have a little cafe
mocha have a hot chocolate
you don't put coffee in yours anymore I
never did the cafe mochas anymore that's
such like that myself you know this
coffee hot chocolate uh you know what I
don't waste any more time let's do it
Josh how did we do last week let's start
their official numbers yeah all right
all right
again I was in Vegas you were at home
yep
and you had your pics done that morning
I did mine in a hotel but where would
did you do yours last week
Toto in his lap yeah in the kitchen
right so let's see how hotel left go did
against home living room Christmas is
doing your picks in a hotel like is that
sound like wow I did my picks in a home
well depending on what you tell me is
where I'm gonna pick my my picks I may
rent a room Thursday heading into last
week the records Sims 81-75 and for left
Co 7680 and for Sims last week you went
five and ten gosh
left go you went 10 and 5 meaning we are
all tied up 86 85 and s phrase in the
record I won five and ten I just want to
look just to see what I did even just
pick you got three game wrong at 4:00
o'clock Sunday night and Monday night
Wow
let's see I just want to see you late so
yep of course I picked Pittsburgh yeah
he didn't cover yeah Arizona didn't
cover like we thought they might right
and then you had Green Bay and Tennessee
bang bang bang ah and then your big one
your biggest bet though was you lost
Washington on Thanksgiving yeah looking
at the bank accounts this is what really
matters
heading into last week you guys were
tied at 160 apiece which I want to say
something I looked back at week
nine of last year it came up on my
timeline at this point last year or a
few weeks ago we were both - thousands
of dollars right so like at this point
last year you were like - to something
and I was - to something and now we're
both in the positives heading into this
week which was good
a mighty positive you are not meet Sims
you lost 600 Bleacher bucks left go you
made 300 bleacher bucks bringing our
totals in the bank accounts heading into
week 13 Sims - 440 left go + 460 that
means I'm now up 900 Bleacher bucks and
we're square so that's in one week it's
not all bad news for you did have a five
and Oh guaranteed to lose week the
Raiders Jets Cardinals and dolphins all
lost so you're 46 and 14 on the year in
guaranteed to lose left go 2 & 1 and
left goes LOX last week only did the
thanksgivings games thanksgiving games
got the Bears got the Saints lost
Washington yeah wash didn't piss me off
Jordan Reed that was 15 yards that would
have been a touchdown that would've been
a cover yeah that was huge it was so
that's where we're at any question well
yeah I have one question
he's just I've never seen a look at the
numbers this I'm actually I'm not even
looking at the numbers I'm trying to
remember who I picked just I'm
interested I went 5 and 10 and then it's
the spread I'm trying to look at back
now and just go wait how did I do just
picking the games outright that's what
I'm really well I would say your biggest
thing yeah is look at all the big
spreads where you set out loud I think
it's too many points right as a gambler
that's what I'm telling you right now
you thought it was too many points for
Washington too many points for Atlanta
in New Orleans too many points for
Oakland and Baltimore too many points
for LA in Arizona and that kind of
[ __ ] in the but yeah you're right have
you noticed how he's just been drop in
the last couple days as a gambling guy
as a gambler I can tell you this yes
Tony Kornheiser calls me a gay gambling
again all the post-match pressors
they're all telling me as the gambling
guy and I'm gonna lean into it and as
somebody that went up 900 and went 10
and 5 last week I think I've earned that
title
absolutely now I'm gonna lose that title
this week well thousand percent going 6
and 10 this week really hoping you guys
ready to start gambling let's do it
first game of the week Thursday Night
Football we already did the preview
yesterday
so we're gonna keep this real preview
here yeah I got a lot of things to say
about bread in this game New Orleans -
seven and a half Sims take it away okay
a great game really a lot of intriguing
matchups on both sides of the ball two
things I think that jump out to me okay
this would be my two main points without
getting too deep in the weeds here the
Saints surviving the initial surge from
the Cowboys the Cowboys are gonna come
out like rabid dogs I really do believe
that Jerry Jones talking about the Super
Bowl all that this is a measuring stick
for them they're trying to show that
they truly are an NFC contender not just
the NFC East contender so I will be
interested just to see if the Saints can
withstand that surge if they can
withstand that surge and only be down by
a score they're gonna be sitting pretty
but if they like that surge happens so
they're down by 10 or 14 games gonna be
very interesting I really think what it
all boils down to right it's just one
thing for me both it's it's an even
matchup up front of both sides of the
ball it really just comes down to Ken if
the Cowboys want to win the game can
they throw the ball in the Saints can
they can they do it consistently through
the game I don't think they're gonna be
able to just run the ball down the
Saints defensive front seven it's good
it's deep it's got everything you wanted
it I really have a hard time believing
that so I just look at it and go can dak
Prescott drop back have a good night can
they make enough big plays because I do
think Dallas defense will slow down the
Saints but slowing down the Saints is
what but how many points 27 right
I mean basically right and you got to
need Dallas to score more than nine
exactly you know or yeah or yes right
I'm just talking about this the game in
general right now so yeah I have a hard
time the Cowboys can slow down the
Saints but that I mean that by ok yeah
they keep him under 30 great job so now
can we say that the Cowboys are gonna
sit here and score more than 24 on the
Saints and I don't know that's too
questionable so I'm betting I'm going a
hundred dollars on the Cowboys such a
weird
I think the Saints win 2721 okay so I
have them winning by six points yeah but
yeah I guess at the end of the day I
just think the Cowboys
I think the Saints are gonna control
this game gotcha
I almost see it's like a 2714 game with
the Cowboys late score kind of thing all
right so everything that we said
yesterday is sensible and it's the
reason the New Orleans Saints should
control this game if Dallas wins the
game last night here's what has to have
happened turnovers sacks and then big
disrupt in place you look at the Saints
only loss this year
it was the season high in lost fumbles -
and sacks three times that has to happen
against Dallas I look at New Orleans and
I go men they've been on a tear the last
few weeks here or the past ranked
defenses that they faced the last three
weeks 26 28 31 Atlanta Philly Cincinnati
those teams in sacks per pass attempt 28
20 - 25 teams that are not good at
defending the pass not good at getting
after the quarterback Dallas has 12 and
7 respectively I even looked up how is
Dallas home after a Thanksgiving game
therefore no the last four times they've
played they're used to it how many times
does Dallas sacked the quarterback at
home versus on the road at home they get
four a game on the road to a game it's
at home on the season in five games
Dallas has turned the ball over two
times at home on the road eight times
right if Dallas protects the ball last
night sacks the quarterback and finds
what I'm trying to talk about the past -
yeah that's how they win that game and I
am predicting the Dallas Cowboys to win
the game 27 to 26 and I am putting $50
on the Cowboys I have talked I I realize
this when when I have sold myself on
something
I am only gonna look up statistics to
back that point so I am very biased I'm
just saying this right now my main thing
is it's a home Thursday game let's not
get that sometimes it's beautiful yeah
and the good thing is it's a full week
that's why I'm excited for the game the
way Dallas is talking about it right now
- yeah yeah yeah can also be bet it
could go bad look I think the Saints
could easily win this game by 30 I'm
just saying I'm picking them there's no
way they'll win by 30 good there's no
way you don't have to worry about that
it's it's really right in this
wheelhouse I don't think you're crazy
for picking the Cowboys to win either
I think there's no way they're gonna get
sacks on this group like you're saying
if they get three when they catch a lot
for the Saints they could get coverage
sacks that's where I look at it we're
being I do think this secondary in
Dallas
I mean Byron Jones is made to guard
Michael Thomas I mean that's gonna be a
funny way seven and a half is a lot it
is a lot it is for a team that's at home
and going to play with insane amount of
energy this is like Titans vs Patriots
is what it feels like to me yeah
alright guys first game on the one
o'clock slate on Sunday the six and five
Baltimore Ravens on the road visiting
the 4 and 7 Atlanta Falcons spread in
this game is Atlanta - 1 it opened as
Baltimore - 3 has now swung all the way
to as high as Atlanta - 1 and a half we
have - 1 as our spread 96% of the money
is going on Atlanta right now why let me
go first then yeah go ahead ok I think
it's because you look at their I'm going
for a sorry Josh do you think Ravens are
having their first road game in a month
right Carolina was the last time they
played on the road right so they've had
two home games and a bye week both
running backs missed practice on
Wednesday Gus Edwards and Collins not
Collins I made him in Collins - I think
it was also the other one how much more
is Allen Tony Jefferson could also miss
this game Ravens are feeling themselves
after beating Cincinnati and Oakland
Atlanta lost on primetime even though
they moved the ball really well with New
Orleans and really could have been tied
in that game and Atlanta is a different
team at home right so I think that it
was you know you started off that - for
and it's swung really heavy I'm just
gonna make my pick I actually have the
Falcons winning this game 26:24 but I'm
only putting $50 on it land
because I do think that Baltimore is the
better team overall I think it's just
this is a Baltimore team that's been in
an incubator for two weeks against
really bad defenses at home and I think
now you're playing an Atlanta team whose
defense is not that good but it's a
Baltimore team on the road against a
high-flying offense so I think it's just
it's an interesting game I will say this
from the gambling guy perspective if
this swings to two or three Atlanta I
would go back to Baltimore cuz I have
Atlanta winning by two so Baltimore was
favored by four early in 93 3i 3 then it
swung all the way now to 1 and a half to
it and you think those are the reasons
why that that's I think if you're making
the argument for Atlanta that's the
argument that you would make gosh okay
so you're clearly on Baltimore so let's
hear it I I am on Baltimore I think this
is a scary matchup for the Atlanta
Falcons I mean they're in danger of
being steamrolled in this game that's
the way I look at I mean the the Browns
and the Cowboys you just look at those
two games alone and I'd go oh in the
Saints last week what happened [ __ ]
Road great session there's one [ __ ] for
you actually there's two now so that's
where I would be scared for Atlanta
settings if you're good at land well I
just don't even understand that I don't
have the take I just don't understand
the line sometimes but that's where I
would worry about you know Atlanta in
this matchup you know they're they're
endangered of being steamrolled by an
offensive team that is in steamroll mode
right now with Lamar and Edwards and
Edwards being banged up will be a big
deal if he can't play and be at a
hundred percent that herd that would
hurt me but also to that like to what we
talked about - Lamar Jackson's been
pretty good in the pocket you don't need
to reinvent the wheel to throw against
Atlanta you know that the Atlanta is not
gonna give you a lot of complicated
looks as is anyways so I guess that's
where I'd worry about it
flipside that too - hey Alana's offense
is very good I know that but they have
not played a defense like this all year
you know this is like not even Dallas
know not just because of the scheme
creativeness here is where they go above
Dallas right my thought was you know the
pass rushers as someone that bet on
Atlanta right thought Baltimore has also
had problems with teams speed this year
yes Carolina Cincinnati taken the edge
they want you to smash it and write
Anna's not trying to play that game
yeah that was my other two thinking boy
yeah I I it's it's it's a good point I
guess it really is cuz when I hear you
talking about Baltimore yeah you always
talk about I'm like their Evander
Holyfield right or George Foreman right
where if they get it inside on you
you're screwed because they're gonna
overpower you and then it's these teams
that can kind of float around and all of
that that I find like creates problems
for them yes I could be wrong I'm just
curious the VI always get what ya know I
mean there's definitely if there's a
weakness to their defense it's still
front seven-speed right yeah there's no
question about that if they can start
getting the edge and doing that against
them then yeah that it will be my
thought it would be trouble certainly I
just I think the Baltimore Ravens are
kind of got it going right now their
secondaries healthy I think they'll be
able to match up at times when they need
be but I think the simpleness of
Atlanta's offense still not being that
great is what scares me at the end of
the day hey I'm betting $100 on the
Baltimore Ravens makes sense I'm picking
the Ravens to win the game outright
I just think they're a tougher kind of
more physical and more creative right
now on both sides of the ball that's
where I give them the advantage I'm
shocked to hear that swing that's a lot
of I and what's what sucks is you never
know if it's like a few big sharps that
are throwing a ton of money and swinging
the line they see a mess up or if this
is the public throwing a lot of money
because if the public's moving it that
much I'm with you like I'm fading the
public hard but for it to have such a
drastic move that's interesting crying
money bet on Baltimore it kind of put my
antennas up I was like I'm gonna join
this Atlanta train I'm see I don't think
I missed anything else all right I'm
good let's go alright next game at one
o'clock or there oh I went 24 20 wavin
the same next game at one o'clock on
Sunday these six and five Carolina
Panthers on the road visiting the 4 & 7
Tampa Bay Buccaneers spread in this game
is Carolina - three and a half weather
on Sunday in Tampa high of 83 partly
cloudy
81 percent humidity Sims yeah definitely
do that because there's a few games
where the weather is a huge part of my
pick all the outdoor games all have
weather awesome all right cool alright I
think there would be
easy as this I mean this is a huge game
for the Carolina Carolina Panthers who
are on a three-game skid here and have
not looked good I do I do I worry about
the Panthers D in this matchup of course
I do
I mean we've seen the last few weeks if
you have a quarterback with some people
on the outside they can get burned
Fitzpatrick trop 20 a few weeks ago
Jackson gets hurt and now you got
Cornell dirt running down the field with
Mike Evans okay well good luck with that
so that's what scares me I think the
only thing that saves Carolina in that
matchup is that just the fact that Tampa
can't run the ball so Carolina right
Carolina doesn't have to put too many
eggs into the stop the run basket which
I think they will play pass heavy early
on in the game pretty hard so yes
there's definitely an advantage in the
pass game from that from that standpoint
of the Bucks offense I think if you just
switched it around I mean I don't know
how the buck stopped the Panthers that's
really where just I get into it and just
go and you know the Panthers offense
they they do a lot of good things they
have big moments don't even be fooled by
the 20 to 19 loss against the the Lions
I mean they moved the ball up and down
the field they missed field goals they
blew a lot of situations same thing last
week as well so I just look at it from
that standpoint and go I don't trust the
Bucks in general and I certainly don't
trust their defense and the Panthers are
in danger of losing their playoff
seedings I just think they're playing
for something more here so I'm betting
$100 on the Carolina Panthers and I'm
picking them to win the game 34
I'm 34 24 34 24 plan for war so I went
back and looked at the last three games
in Tampa between cam and Jameis right
cam went to and won the two wins Bart
were by 14 points each
but both quarterbacks have been super
sloppy when these two teams have played
in Tampa cam is only averaging in Tampa
in those three games a hundred and
seventy-one yards per game he had four
touchdowns four interceptions and sacked
five times he has not played well really
in any game there
Jamis and those games is averaging 233
yards per game three touchdowns seven
interceptions
eight sacks so this is a very sloppy
game to me just it has a tradition of
being that way yeah Carolina has owned
Tampa 8 and 2 in their last 10 7 and 3
straight up it's just one of the team's
the NFC South they own but the thing
that scares me about this Carolina team
as I mentioned last week and correctly
predicted they score over 27 points is
they're a different team on the road
like really bad on the road slow against
Philadelphia slow against Washington got
their ass kicked by Pittsburgh they're 1
in 6 straight up and against the spread
in their last seven road games going to
last year I am picking the Carolina
Panthers to win 31 24 and I am putting
$50 on Carolina
because I am afraid of Carolina as a
road team and Tampa Bay is one of those
weird teams like Buffalo that when they
have a home game and it's a little bit
humid it gets a little bit weird yeah so
I'm joining you with Carolina
I'm only doing 50 even though I have
them as a seven point winner I you're
gonna see I have a lot of those this
week where I go well my team picked the
spread but I'm there's a few things that
scare me about putting a lot of money on
it yeah
Carolina's at home they're winning by 21
yeah they're on the road not so much
okay we've just seen you know even the
games you mention it just it's hard to
trust Carroll on him right now the games
they've lost they have found a way to
screw it up other than the Steelers game
where they were just outright beat but
the other ones it's we can all go back
to those games and go you know like last
week with the no conversion interception
thank you judge scores based on total
yards and not points Carolina might be
undefeated right right all right guys
next game at one o'clock the eight and
three Chicago Bears on the road visiting
the three and eight New York Giants
spreading this game is Chicago - four
and a half whether in East Rutherford at
MetLife Stadium on Sunday showers in the
morning cloudy in the afternoon high of
59 Sims high of 59 okay all right so it
sounds like we're not gonna get Mitchell
true Biscay right it's gonna be chase
Daniel at quarterback for the most part
and this one I think when I start there
hey it's hard to really trust the Giants
defense right now and the way they're
playing football I mean they're a
disaster you know I don't know what
other what other way to say it
they don't do a single thing well that
not really I agree have nothing to hang
their hat on there they really don't um
can't get pressure on the quarterback
let up your yards rushing let up big
place in the past game really one of the
disappointments of the year and the
whole NFL is the way their defense is
played now the Bears offense Rams by the
way applaud them for letting go of Alec
Ogletree they did a good job it was a
small - cord at the right - exactly
right
I think the yet the so but the Bears
offense like chase Daniels was not good
last week well it was nothing special I
mean he missed a lot of place and a lot
of throws and people were open and hey a
chances a few times just make plays and
kind of really put Detroit in a bad spot
and he didn't do that so I guess I worry
about that aspect a little bit not to
where I think they're gonna be stopped
but just whether they can take advantage
of some of the big plays that are there
to be had right then I flip it over and
I just look at the Giants and III you
know I don't know how you feel about it
but I would certainly say this is the
best defense the Giants have played this
year I know they played the Cowboys
early on in the year and had a deal with
that but again what I go to in these
days wasn't the Cowboys defense back
exactly right and what what I think is
different about this defense too is the
Bears are you know they're they're are a
game plan specific defense to like you
know like I talked about with Baltimore
some of the they can play man-to-man but
they can also get you in certain
formations and drop people all of the
right areas and their breakdowns of
offenses are very good so they have a
little familiarity with Shermer they're
I think they're pass rush should be an
issue for the New York Giants throughout
the day I just have a hard time seeing
the Giants winning this football game of
course I'm betting $100 on the Bears
I think they win 24 to 17 so one thing I
did was I looked back last year week 13
yeah and I'm like man I'm picking a lot
of blowouts I just want to see what it
was like last year last year week 13
there were six games decided by 16 or
more points five of them were by 20 or
more and 9 of the 16 games were by
double digits because I believed in Josh
asked me this what does that even matter
it matters to me because at this point
of the year we're no longer finding
ourselves we have a pretty good sample
size of who these teams are they know
what their identities are and I feel
like in week 13 you're either pushing
for the playoffs where you're sitting
your ass on the side pretty much and I
feel like that's when these teams start
to separate themselves yeah I went back
and look how did Adele do against Vic
Fangio the one time that he faced him
right Vic Fangio clearly focused on him
cuz he went 5 for 46 yeah now sterling
Sheppard got 11 targets in that game
right 5 for 50 and a touchdown I imagine
that's how the Bears are gonna play it
this time focus on Odell focus on sake
one hope Khalil Mak can get to the
quarterback they're gonna own the
interior part of the Giants offensive
without I mean Hakeem Hicks and Eddie
Goldman are gonna be tossing around will
Hernandez like a salad after they blew
the game to Carolina the Giants where
they had the successful comeback and
then it slipped away right the next game
they got blown out at home by the Eagles
and it really wasn't competitive at all
right they just blew a comeback against
the Eagles yeah Chicago is coming on 10
day arrest so now with one game of all
the jitters out for our man chase Daniel
Wright and not having us to figure out
the the first-day reps remember they
didn't even practice before that
Thursday game right they were just doing
walkthroughs before thanks Mike Colt
McCoy Redskins that was stupid it makes
sense but now chase Daniel has another
10 days as the starter and he's probably
known the entire time you're probably
going to be the starter I have the
Chicago Bears winning this game 32 to 12
and I am putting a hundred and fifty
dollars on the Chicago Bears that is the
sound of sake one being tackled by four
guys like Raj Khalil max hauling on
don't do the sound again and say Kwan's
like and he can't get free say Quan is
going to be a caged bear on Sunday this
is this is a this is the by the way did
you hear the Francesa rant blaming
everything on Odell saying that he
hasn't heard and heister ever since
Odell has been here it's been awful it's
not Eli's fault it's not the coach's
fault it's these diva wide receivers
that don't win anything and he goes you
know what Odell's record is since he's
gotten here 29 and 41 because I always
associate win-loss record with wide
receiver who doesn't ya know I think
France s it's because you're defending
Eli because he's paid your bills for 15
years and Odell didn't show up to a
charity breakfast one time and you're
very upset next game on the one o'clock
slate to the 4 and 7 Buffalo Bills on
the road visiting the 5 & 6 Miami
Dolphins spread in this game is Miami -
four and a half opened at Miami - 7 it's
down to four and a half now whether in
Florida on Sunday high of 83 cloudy in
the afternoon
82 percent
okay um bills are one of my favorite
teams in football just want everybody to
know that I love their ugly style of
play and just mucking a game up and of
course I like Josh Allen - but I'm like
such a fan of Sean McDermott I'm like
truly fanboy you know what's great is
Sean McDermott looks like an Irish boxer
in the 30s and his football team plays
like exactly right he looks like metal
person right I think you're a boxer he
looks like somebody that he would get
pushed in a bar and he'd go one second
there lad and like take a sip a beer be
like you're in for a rude oh I got him
yeah he really does look like me and
left go had an experience like that at a
bar three years ago actually it's not
okay
okay the bills going to Miami the first
thing I just go let's go Bills offense
verse the Miami defense well we know the
bills offense it's not real versatile
but the one area they have a chance in
in this game is the fact that I do think
they're gonna be able to run the ball on
the Miami Dolphins even the Miami raw
dolphins run defense is absolutely
abysmal and it's something that the
bills can do somewhat well especially
with Josh Allen at quarterback - because
you do have to worry about him on
bootlegs or keeping the ball on the read
option or something like that to where
he can threaten that backside even more
so that alone gives them a little more
chance than normal on offense because it
should help open up their pass game to a
degree now what scares me on that side
of the ball though is this still you
know the bills own line trying to block
these edge guys for the Dolphins the
Dolphins don't have enough big guys in
the middle but they do have a wave of
pass rushers on the edge I mean they're
really one of the few teams we've seen
in the last six to seven weeks even get
close to Andrew Luck on a consistent
basis like they did last week so that's
where it can be interesting in that
matchup but can the Dolphins offense do
anything against the bills I mean that's
really what it is
and I actually have trachs banged up and
right right where I get into that is
just going man okay we've talked about
McDormand a million times if you have a
simple offense
he is gonna have his guys all over your
crap so I would get worried about Miami
and their lack of you know inventions in
the past game on the offensive side of
the ball and of course the bills are
awesome unde offense I mean the only
time the bills fall apart on defense is
just when their offense is so bad and
some of those Derrick Anderson games and
Nathan Peterman games that they were out
there every 35 seconds again and they
just kind of fell apart and got worn out
so I think this is a very close football
game I'm going out on a limb here and
picking the bills to win the game I'm
putting $100 on the bills I think this
is the type of game I think this is the
type of game though they can make really
ugly and win a 1716 type of game down in
Miami and Josh Allen can make two or
three plays with shady McCoy that gets
them over the hump let me read you the
last one two three four five six games
at the Miami Dolphins have allowed in
terms of rushing yards 118 to Indy
hundred ninety five to Green Bay 80 to
the Jets 188 to Houston 248 to Detroit
164 to Chicago it's unbelievable so last
six weeks that's unreal and like the New
York Jets had no offense at all like
Josh McCowan's first game right got a
lot of stuff here dolphins are 4 & 1 at
home
wild crap has happened for the dolphin
at home for their really has seven hour
game against Tennessee I keep bringing
it up the Chicago Bears game where the
ball was bouncing Oakland really
dominated Miami the entire game and a
few big plays happen right and then
Miami beat the Jets at home so those are
their four wins so it's not that
interesting
Shawn McDermott last season against Adam
GaSe bills versus dolphins again it was
a weird year for both teams but Shawn
McDermott swept him tuna - OH
but in both games around the third
quarter or fourth quarter buffalo was
leading the first game 24 to 6 and they
were leading the second game 22 to 3
right it was late scores in both games
that made it look more respectable
in both games Shawn McDermott diagnosed
Adam GaSe his offense in a second and
said I'm taking away with us I'm taking
away that yeah
Buffalo's turnovers is up there they're
one the most turnover teen in the NFL
but I looked in the six games without
Josh Allen they have 16 turnovers in the
five games with Josh Allen they have
five turnovers oh he's such a rookie
that he's so low all over the place
can't trust them this is the Buffalo
team they run time Buffalo and Baltimore
are very similar our defenses are gonna
figure you out we're gonna pound you
with the run and we have a very athletic
quarterback that's gonna take the edge
when you make it available I have the
Buffalo Bills winning this game twenty
three to twenty and I love the plus four
and a half I will be honest I had a lot
of money I took a little bit to put
somewhere else and then I took a little
bit off to put somewhere else because
it's still Buffalo so I'm only betting
$100 on Buffalo but I love the plus four
days yeah I hear you and I think I'm
gonna make them a left go lock I'm which
is crazy
the only thing I look at is just going
and just yeah can if the Dolphins can
run the ball that's their only their
only hope you know what's funny
even if they can they're gonna use Frank
Gore so I'm really not worried about
yeah what did you say Drake is banged up
with Drake's issue Drake came out of
last I haven't my fantasy team that's
why I know but he's questionable he sat
out of practice with his wrist or
whatever something like the shoulder
shoulder was limited in Wednesday's
practice Miami should play if they don't
get the the blocked punt or the or the
70 yard touchdown their offense just
doesn't have a flow no they really don't
have any identity and Buffalo's gonna
just take away a few main things and say
let's play in a box right yeah
next game at 1:00 o'clock here these six
and five Indianapolis claims also
resonate three and eight Jacksonville
Jaguars spread in this game is Colts
minus four and the weather in
Jacksonville on Sunday it is a high of
eighty with 86% humidity okay very humid
in Florida is very human it's called
climate change okay here we go
you're loving me today are take it away
Laura's yours or is mine okay um Colts
are banged up football team I know that
that's what scares me a little bit in
the matchup I mean both sides of the
ball banged up banged up bang Marlon Mac
could be out Joyal is out right various
Leonard's banged up right Oh their
injury list has been like 14 people long
but before you keep going Jacksonville
Jalen Ramsey could miss the game Leonard
fournette is out yeah Cody Kessler is
starting yep so which and they just lost
nor well right so nor well being out
huge a course for net is the best player
on their offense that is HUGE Cody
Kessler improvement okay so now we go to
that Colts can they move it on the Jags
I mean I think they can move it on the
Jags yes I don't think it's going to be
easy with or without Jalen Ramsey it's
not gonna really totally dictate you
know how I look at this game this Jags
defense is still really good but I do
think at the end of the day with the
newfound balanced attack that the Colts
have their ability to pass protect that
they should be able to make enough plays
in the pass game because we know Andrew
Luck will stand there all day and and
wait for people to get open down the
field now I don't think they're gonna
come up with some of the big place we
saw a few weeks ago in that game where
Jacksonville busted some coverages I
would have a hard time thinking
Jacksonville gets caught by surprise
with some of that stuff this time around
I really would so I do think that the
the Jags defense will play better now on
the other side of the ball yeah the Jags
should be able to move the ball and even
without fournette or nor well should be
able to move the ball in the run game to
keep them honest they're gonna have the
three-step drop pass game which they
can't really do with Blake bortles Cody
Kessler we saw the last time he got in
that's what he did really the first you
know drive he did went right down the
field got the ball of his hands and they
call it a number of plays that they
really don't ever call with Blake
bortles cuz he's not capable of doing
them so I think that's where it could be
interesting but of course the Jags
they're weak to everything they've had
the firing of the coach the bench eagle
Blake bortles not knowing if Ramsey can
play all of that and especially with no
Leonard fournette there is no freaking
way I'm picking the Jags to win the
football game I think they give a
spirited effort
certainly and I'm picking them to cover
the spread but I do think the Colts win
the game 23 to 20 mmm loans how much oh
I bet $100 so the last time Andrew Luck
played in Jacksonville was not 2017 it
was 2016 so it wasn't the magical
defense of last year right Colts lost 27
to 30 Andrew Luck threw for 234 yards
two touchdowns one interception and was
sacked 6-times
the Colts have also not been on the road
in over a month
right all these games have been at home
Andrew Luck has 11 interceptions this
year seven of them are on the road so
that dome Marlin Mack maybe not being
there Jack Doyle remember Eric Ebron was
the one that squeaked out against
Jacksonville last time he's not
squeaking out anywhere I look at this
also as a short Colts win you said 23 to
20 I did I'm going 22 to 19 Colts win
and I am putting $50 on the Jacksonville
jack yeah I hear you yeah I don't expect
the Colts to go down there and just run
over the jacks no no no and especially
being that banged up especially with
Jacksonville blowing the amount of
Symonds they did the first time around
because be a little more buttoned up
look I think you can look at the first
game between the Colts in the Jaguars
two ways you can go wow the Jaguars
really got back in that game just
dumping the ball down to running backs
well that's gonna be a better part of
their offense because TJ Yeldon played a
lot he's gonna play a lot at this game
and they're gonna be at home but I also
look at the Colts offense in that game
two plays to Eric Ebron where he was
completely wide open yeah a catch in the
back of the end zone by a backup tight
end who it's still arguable if he caught
it or not right and and the Colts were
you know they were not solid with a lot
of their execution either I still say
this Jordan Wilkins fumbling problem
could be a big issue against the Jaguars
and I'm not a hundred percent set on
Nayeem Hinds I just think that a lot of
the weapon if Doyle and Mack are out
it's a lot of weapons missing for the
Colts yeah but if Jalen Ramsey's
there I have a lot more confidence in T
Y Hilton yeah yep
alright guys next game on Sunday the
four six and one Cleveland Browns on the
road visiting the eight and three
Houston Texans spreading this game is
Houston minus five and a half Sims yeah
okay so um hey the the Browns kind of
got it going right now especially with
what they're doing on the offensive side
of the ball we talked about it a lot
their offensive line is very good they
found the run game they they really of
doing a good job of designing plays and
things that Baker Mayfield does really
well and putting that on the offense
it's all it's all great I just don't see
the Browns being able to run the ball on
the Houston Texans as as much as I like
this Browns offensive line it's really
good
I think this front seven for the Texans
is pretty special I mean they got
everything you want I mean it doesn't
matter I mean you want to get big well
they can get giant I mean you want to
get quick well they can they got more
hybrid and linebacker /dn guys than any
team in football so I look at that and
go okay there's a disadvantage of the
Browns I don't think they can run the
ball now in the past game you know the
Texans couldn't let up some pass big
plays in the past game from time to time
they're they're not immune to that
because they will they go for the kill
at times with what they do on defense
they try to totally smother you and you
know there for somebody might be
streaking wide open down the field
because they put too many eggs and oh we
think they're gonna do this concept and
this formation and they get burned by it
every now and that but I think this is
unlike really any defense Baker has seen
to this point with just as multiple and
as unique as they are not only with the
front seven but the coverage is on the
back end and you know I think on the
other side of the ball I just go for the
Cleveland Browns
I think Houston's offense is just to
balance for Cleveland Cleveland's
defense is admirable in some areas but
certainly not special I know that and I
and even though they have miles Garrett
they do not get to the quarterback no
they don't and Miles Garrett's really
the only guy that can get to the
quarterback by himself without getting a
scheme blitz or anything like that now
that would be the biggest thing in the
game though there really will be the
only way
I see the Browns winning this game if
there's a weakness to the use of text as
we've talked about their run game you
know their tackles and pass protection
you know last week it wasn't good
neither against the Tennessee Titans but
we just saw deshaun Watson move around
and make so many amazing plays to get
out of the pocket that we forgot like oh
he didn't really get sacked that many
times he wasn't under pressure so I do
worry about that being the game changer
but the balance the Texans have shown
with running the ball and then I know
their past game is not like reinventing
the wheel but it's good enough yeah I
think they're gonna put you know the
Cleveland Browns in a tough spot in this
one so I'm betting $100 on the Houston
Texans I like that Nicki I didn't know
where the hell that was going rolling
man I'm throwing in I'm going and I just
don't think the browsing GEB yeah 27:17
Texans interesting interesting I wrote
down my first note yeah I don't think
the Browns can do anything I call this a
skirt game yeah a lot like the Ravens
you've been cruising for a few weeks
against some [ __ ] defenses and skirt
real defense shows up and it's I have to
imagine when you think you're clicking
and then a team comes on the field
that's it's such a higher level on one
side of the unit than anyone you face
the last few weeks yeah it's got to be
jarring it definitely is Browns have
beaten the Falcons and the bengals right
and boy they've putting up some points
63 points the last two weeks
you know how the great philosopher
Aristotle said no about three games a
year you really put out that primetime
effort oh excuse me that was Phil Simms
I believe the Browns did that last week
right damarious Randall said I'm gonna
give this interception ball to Hugh
Jackson the rest of this week Baker
Mayfield's been responding to instagrams
and talked and defending his honor right
taking his eyes off the prize
here come the Texans and it's not just
the Texans it's the Texans at home Jeff
Driskel
came in the game and went 17 to 29 for
155 and a touchdown right Jeff Driskel
yeah I covered this guy in the Sugar
Bowl and I looked and said this guy
stinks he stinks
Matt Sims would throw circles around
Jeff Driskel I look at this game and I
have the Texans winning
27:17 it's our first ever shared score
nice job guys but I'm putting a hundred
and fifty dollars on that's it let me
tell you about a team called the tick
Sims here let me go through the amount
of rushing yards the Texans have loud
it's gonna make you look at your pick
and make you feel so proud hundred five
two Tennessee 124 to Washington 75 to
the Bronx 116 to Miami and 70 to them
Jacksonville Jaguars
they held the Dallas Cowboys 298 yards
rushing Carlos Hyde's gonna go down
James Jadeveon Clowney is a big boy JJ
Watt this is my bold social moments
prediction Oh JJ Watt is gonna sack
Baker Mayfield and then go to shake his
hand and keep him at arm's length he's
doing this one for you I think the
Texans might even win this game by more
than that but I got a lot of confidence
in the Texans and I might left go lock
them up
alright guys next game here at one
o'clock on Sunday the five and six
Denver Broncos on the road visiting the
five and six Cincinnati Bengals spread
in this game is Denver minus five
weather in Cincinnati on Sunday is sunny
with a high of 61 Chris okay
Cincinnati's offense Driscoll you just
mentioned it all those things stunk in
the Sugar Bowl stunk in the Sugar Bowl
it's gonna be a lot of Joe Mixon you
know I don't even put into the stock of
what he did last week either I mean the
game was thirty-five seven you know the
Browns are just kind of in let's get out
of here mode AJ Green his health status
does give them a chance to a degree you
know there's is always a few chances to
throw big pass play
down the field on the Denver Broncos
like we saw last week with Pittsburgh I
mean they missed a few they hit a 97
yard touchdown that that will happen
with Denver they're aggressive you know
they will have moments where they're
gonna put their corners in some some
favorable spots if you got a good wide
receiver so that's that scares me a
little bit but the bangles D I mean what
what are you like come on I don't know
what the what there's nothing to say
about it there's nothing good they got
two good corners that's the only thing I
can look at right now in Geno Atkins
other than that everything is very
average and led up a lot of big plays
and this is a Broncos offense that looks
for a big place I mean this is not the
bra you know the Broncos are not like Oh
check down charlie and we want to go on
twelve play drives I mean they're
they're capable of doing that but they
want 40 yards out of Emmanuel Sanders
Philip Lindsay off the edge 420 that's
kind of how their drives usually go so
yeah because of that of course I'm
picking the Denver Broncos there's no
way in my right mind I would pick the
bengals to do anything here so $100 on
the Denver Broncos and I think the
Broncos win the game 24 to 17 so it's
gonna be all Joe Mixon
and then can Jeff Driskel hit AJ Green
on deep passes I don't know if he can't
I will say this though the Broncos are a
different team on the road they're one
good road game was against the Chargers
that do not have a home-field advantage
what was the weather in this game
weather boy weather in this game sunny
with a high of 61
don't call me weather boy thank you just
remember to do your job okay I did
actually
so I when I came up with my score I had
the Broncos winning this game 20 to 16
right the main reason I have it like
that is I believe the Broncos just came
off of one of their games of the year
with a win over the Steelers they're
gonna there's no reason for me to like
this that's why I'm only putting $50 on
the Bengals plus five
I'm not even gonna do a sound effect
because I don't feel confident that just
my score came out that way yeah that's
okay I'm just I'm seeing a sluggish
Broncos team making the one o'clock trip
on the East Coast after beating the
Steelers at home and I just think that
they're a different team on the road and
this is not a Bengals are gonna play
good game this is a I feel like the
Broncos are gonna come out sloppy and I
think this is gonna be the other side of
Case Keenum game yeah it could be I I
hear you there there's definitely I just
don't have faith in the Broncos like the
Broncos are one of those teams where
they beat these two gate teams
everyone's like watch out for them
making a playoff run it was like perfect
time to bet against them yeah I guess my
mind yeah the Joe Mixon thing will be
sir that's the only way the Bengals have
a chance I see yeah and they're there
Broncos run D it stinks it's been good
though the last four weeks they've
they've kind of corrected it ever since
then I don't they played love him though
except that Rams game I mean they kind
of have if you go back through like
their the Rams games game that was their
second week of letting over 200 yards of
rushing they've kind of righted the ship
they've stopped asking guys to do like
like how I was talking about in the Jets
can remember where the linebacker had to
cover the tight end made the man and
also read responsible for the B gap and
then the tight end would just release on
a run play and he's chasing after you
know the tight end and then Olson
there's no one there for the B gap and
it's a 40 yard gain and they've stopped
doing that stupid crap so sometimes I go
to this website Vegas insider just to
see how the lines are moving and where
the money is going yeah and the line
started off at 3 and a half which in
that case I would have been on Denver
but it's moved to five but the same way
that it's moved from three and a half to
five almost 80% of the money is going on
Cincinnati but most of the spread bets
are going on Denver so when I see that I
usually go the sharps are betting on
Cincinnati but more bets are coming in
on Denver so that's why I'm also that
made me feel more confident when I
looked at my scores got you all right
guys next game at 1:00 o'clock here the
ten-in-one LA Rams on the road visiting
the 4 & 7 Detroit Lions spread in this
game is la minus 10 Chris Simms
ok the Rams
offence versa Lions defense had the
Brandt the the Lions defense has
straightened out their run defense to a
degree with snacks being there his first
game
I think his first game was like the
Seattle Seahawks which wasn't great and
that one but ever since then it's been
pretty damn good as far as slowing down
the run they don't get gashed like they
were earlier in the year against the
Miami Dolphins and some of those other
games that they play it but I just have
a hard time looking at this Detroit
defense who just doesn't have a lot of
special football players being able to
slow the Rams down consistently through
the game this Rams defense I I know
Cooper cups no longer there it doesn't
matter they still got weapons galore
they're extremely balanced they've had a
long time prepare I don't think they're
the type of team that's going to come
out flat off of a by a week I'm gonna
just rely on just some of the coaches I
know their their energy the way they go
about their business I'm putting my
faith in and then from that standpoint
on and then I look at the other side of
the ball and okay it looks like we're
gonna have to keep to lead back right or
no he's not seeing but probably next
okay it sounds like all right so either
way doesn't really matter
um I think no carry on Johnson or him
not being a hundred percentage really I
mean that's it for me if there's any
weakness to the Rams and what they do it
is like okay you can run the ball up the
middle and smashmouth them you know the
garret blunts good but he's not gonna
make that one guy missed to make a
five-yard gain into a 25-yard gain like
carry on and Johnson he ain't doing it
in back-to-back weeks so I wouldn't
expect that either um so I just go and
then you know I'm excited to hear your
score there's just too much talent on
the Rams over the Lions I just don't
know how the Lions can really keep pace
throughout the day and also keep people
off of Matt Stafford's back and most
importantly there's no one in the past
game that scares you like Kenny G
holiday is a good player we know that
but he's not gonna burn people for like
oh gosh we got to put a safety over the
top because he'll go 70 yards so either
way I'm picking the Rams for $100
and I picked them to win the game 31 to
21 I look at this game and I thought one
thing and one thing only
ooh Shawn McVeigh has an extra week to
watch them on film mm-hmm Shawn McVeigh
beats the Chiefs then gets an off week
and then gets to play a team last year
off of a bye
Rams had a by the Giants had a bye and
LA went into the Giants and beat their
ass yes that was the game where they
converted a third and 33 for a 52-yard
touchdown Robert Woods right I have the
Rams winning this game
41 to 14 whoo whoo and I am putting a
hundred and fifty dollars on the Rams to
cover the spread got you this game yeah
that's Shawn McVeigh going how bad you
want to beat him boys bad 41 to 14 carry
on Johnson Marvin Jones no one to scare
me on offense they I'm just I'm not
worried about it
yeah I hear you I'm really not worried
about it no no I mean III understand
that completely
I mean the only thing you got to worry
about with the Rams is just they gonna
let up big plays that's that's really
all it comes down to I mean and that's
that I don't think there's offense for
the Lions is designed to have big plays
no there's not a lot of people that are
gonna scare you that's for sure
all right guys last game at one o'clock
on Sunday the 2 & 9
Arizona Cardinals on the road visiting
the 4 6 & 1 Green Bay Packers spread in
this game is Green Bay minus 14 and it
will be snowing in Green Bay on Sunday
Oh Chris
how will the Rosen one do in the snow
mmm
okay nose and one Packers defense our
Packers
yeah defense verse two Cardinals offense
I mean of course we know the Cardinals
offense is not special the Packers will
play some man-to-man and give guys like
Larry Fitzgerald or a Christian Kirk to
have some opportunity to run by or catch
back shoulder footballs you know I like
the Packers scheme you know that I'm big
fan of what Mike Pettine is done this
year but the big thing with the Packers
where I look in this game he says I just
they're not gonna overwhelm the
Cardinals the Packers aren't gonna
overwhelm anybody on defense they're
just
not talented enough you know you know
like we've said I mean Mike Daniels I
don't know what his status is for the
game in general but he won't be a
hundred percent I know that and we
talked about Gyre Alexander earlier in
the week and how special he is but other
than that there's not a lot to like just
love Kenny Clarke's good he's not great
there's a lot of just good on Green Bay
but nobody really great other than Joe
Alexander and Mike Daniels Daniel's out
a few weeks could miss the rest of the
season all right so yeah that that that
bothers me for this matchup and then the
other side of the ball you know Green
Bay um I think Green Bay's gonna have a
hard time against this Arizona defense I
do I don't think they're gonna just
march up and down the field listen they
got Aaron Rodgers and we know he'll make
a few plays but I look at Arizona as
being very similar to like like a
buffalo when they get a clue of your
offense and they feel like they got a
beat on it they are gonna be all over
some of your schemes and you guys have
heard me a million times tell you how
simple Green Bay is and I have I think
that they're gonna be all over their
schemes added to the fact we're okay
teams are over there schemes a lot well
the other thing that would bother me in
this matchup you know Aaron Rodgers can
take over games we know that I don't
think he can take over this game not
against this pass rush in this front for
Chandler Jones is other than Aaron
Donald and JJ Watt is the third best
pass rusher in the game
Marcus golden is good you know Gunter's
good we saw Kim dieci sighting last week
so I think they're gonna be able to get
pressure would therefore and contain
Rodgers a little bit and keep seven so
at the end of the day I'm betting it
I'm betting with the Arizona Cardinals
here I'm putting $100 on it I wanted to
go hard all right
yes you forgot to migrate south little
birdie it's a little cold up here in
Green Bay you're probably going to die
today but I'm picking the Packers to win
23 to 17 yep
since 2009 Rogers 15 and Oh in December
14 and one against the spread this year
at home baba yaga is four oh and one at
home Baba Yaga Baba Yaga the domed
Cardinals come to flurry Lambeau and as
the snow falls and the temperature skies
towards the ground so do the frozen
wings this isn't about the jimmies or
the joes or the x's or the oles this is
about the flurries and the snows the
reign of aaron rogers begins right now
31:10 Packers win $50 who's in John wick
your classics you're watching they're a
lot of people love it stop - movie
all-time for you it's not in my top 5
all right guys moving on to the
afternoon games 405 Eastern Time the
nine and two Kansas City Chiefs back in
action on the road visiting the 2 & 9
Oakland Raiders spread in this game is
Kansas City - 15 Chris all right all
right all right I'm pulling up the teams
here I don't know what to say
Oakland 2 & 9 yeah
Oakland - what to say I mean Andy Reed
bye week Raiders defense stinks Raiders
defense is horrible at stopping the run
the Raiders defense is horrible that's
stopping the pass hmmm Chiefs can do all
of those hmm
Andy Reed against the by one more time
just like to say that ok flip it over to
the other side Chiefs defense not real
good we understand that but Raiders
offense not real good either offensive
line shaky one thing the Chiefs can do
is rush the passer I do think they're
gonna give up early then the Raiders
were going to have to pass block to get
back into the game I think that's gonna
lead to a disaster and long story short
I'm betting $100 on the Chiefs I'm
chickening out throughout the week
I'm only betting a hundred but I am
going Chiefs 38 Raiders 21 good break
down Chiefs 28 38 38 21 yeah
since hiring Andy Reed the Chiefs have
gone 8 and 2 against the Raiders and
guess what the Chiefs just had Chris
Simms a bye week and how does Andy Reed
do after the bye amazing there's nobody
better 16 and 3 after the bye and he
lost and he lost last year the Giants
after the boat Wow yeah which means he's
gonna go five more years without losing
when they got on their cold streak I
worried a little bit can the Raiders
lose by 14 or more what's gonna happen
that seems like kind of a big spread 15
points oh no the Raiders have lost seven
games this year by 14 or more points I
am going the Chiefs 44 to 17 and I am
putting $100 dice on the cheese I pick
it out huh I chickened out no I had more
games I like more oh okay you didn't
like a 27 point victory huh
no because what 15 is a big number
yeah I know well I have other ones I
like okay
all right guys next game here at 4:05
the three and eight New York Jets on the
road visiting the five and six Tennessee
Titans spread in this game is Tennessee
- seven and a half Chris Sims yeah the
Jets offense it is concerning I think
overall right now
I mean you know I just think this is a
tough matchup but then I look at it you
know that the Jets not really great in
any one area on the offensive side of
the ball also a little predictable on
the defensive side of the ball I always
worry about with that with a guy like
Dean piece so there he is he doesn't
really have to totally respect the run
now he can dial up a lot of Defense's
and coverages that take away some of the
past game of the New York Jets if he
needs to stop the run or get some
pressure on the quarterback what scares
you on the Jets in the past game anyways
and the Titans still have a solid
secondary that certainly can match up
from time to time and play man-to-man
against this group if the Jets do have
some success running the ball now the
Jets D could slow down the Titans - III
do recognize that you know the Titans
are I don't really know what to say
about the Titans as an offense I have a
very not a good feel for what they are
really I really don't it's kind of big
plays here and there you know I don't
know I don't even know what to say about
it I'm kind of at a loss of work all
over the place they are for what my take
is on it I don't know what I can really
depend on there's been weeks where
they've run the ball well there's been
weeks where they've thrown the ball well
there's been weeks where they've done
none of that together but either way I
just look at it and just think the
Titans are the better team they're at
home and I just have no faith in the
Jets offense in the matchup I think the
D can make the game ugly for a while and
it could be like a 17-14 type game but
then I see the Titans scoring late to
kind of put it away somewhere in there
in the mid fourth court or something
like that so I'm putting $100 on the
Titans and I'm picking them to win 24 to
14 so for only the second time in three
weeks that Titans her home and the
Titans are a very good home team they're
just when they're at home everything's
clicking the defense is getting after
the quarterback Marcus Mariota looks
comfortable I also don't think that Jets
had the passing game to take advantage
of those secondary lapses right Titans
have one-on-one matchups right and if
Sam dar
his back which he might be I don't know
if if he's gonna be ready for that on a
road trip like that to Tennessee the
last two games the Jets have also
allowed over 200 rushing yards in both
of those games
Buffalo and New England so I don't know
if this is a Derrick Henry game but you
know those happen like once a blue moon
it's like Halley's Comet I have the Jets
also scoring 14 I have the Titans
scoring 28 and I'll be putting $100 as
well on the Tennessee Titans Sam toggles
you haven't texted out of left go back
and because of that you shall suffer a
double-digit loss at the hands of my toy
toes your hair is wavy I think your
49ers thing is I mean not your 49ers
your Titans voice might be my new
favorite it is it's surpassed the Raven
yeah
well I've lost the Ravens well it was
the other one his Jaguar one is pretty
good too hey doesn't yeah a lot of
opportunities to do it this year no I
know I know
alright guys 425 on Sunday the 2 and 9
San Francisco 49ers on the road visiting
the 6 and 5 Seattle Seahawks spread in
this game Seattle - nine and a half
whether in Seattle on Sunday high of 45
partly cloudy okay I have a fantasy
question for you after this okay so the
Seahawks offense I don't think is going
to have its way with the 49ers defense
I think the 49ers defense actually
matches up pretty good with the Seahawks
as far as what they want to do I mean
the 49ers they keep a lot of people at
the line of scrimmage they play a lot of
single safety defense they're hard to
run the ball on they're a big physical
group on the defensive front seven so I
look at it from that standpoint and just
go I don't think the Seahawks are gonna
be able to mash the ball down the throat
of the San Francisco 49ers continually
now really the big question there is
just those one-on-one matchups I talked
about on the outside you know Russell
Wilson and those receivers you know the
game can be not great on their side of
the ball from time to time but they seem
to always
strike with four or five big plays a
game when they find man-to-man coverage
and Russell throws a great deep ball or
a deep crosser or wherever that may be
so I just think that the Hawks offense
could be you know hit or miss throughout
periods of the game I guess that's what
scares me now the other side of the ball
I do again think that the San Francisco
49ers are gonna run the ball on the
Seattle Seahawks I really did I mean
Seattle got annihilated last week on
defense
I mean annihilated and I do think
there's gonna be certain things that
Kyle Shannon will be able to take from
that game plan the 49ers have to be
embarrassed by the way they played last
week their whole week in general but of
course I have no faith in either one of
their you know fourth-string
quarterbacks
so that of course is the big determining
factor for me I it's on the road in
Seattle I'm putting $100 on the San
Francisco 49ers
[Music]
what was your score you screwed it up
not me are you sure yeah robbing your
thoughts no look at the email look at
our original email check I am picking
the Seahawks to only win by four twenty
four to twenty so the last ten in these
two games Seattle's won nine and won the
last six games for the Niners on the
road oh and six the last six games in
Seattle for the Niners they're one in
five against the spread last seven games
for Seattle in general five 101 against
the spread over the care I look at this
game on the score that I came out with
was Seattle winning 26 to 17 that's nine
I'm putting $50 on San Francisco to
cover the spread
just when you think you got me I pull
you back in here's my question my own
personal fantasy question yeah I have
two defenses that I could play Seattle
against San Francisco or Jacksonville at
home against India here's my thing with
Seattle yeah biggest fear and it will
get back to the game this is a cover
three press bail against Kyle Shanahan
yeah all he does is eat those defenses
for lunch yeah but it's still in Seattle
with Nick Mullen right but I'm looking
at this game and it's cover three press
bail versus cover three press bail right
and I got to think that like Seattle's
gonna go let's take a few shots at
Richard sure yeah
great let's let's let's let's put Tyler
Lockett on Richard Sherman and see what
happens right but I don't know about
Seattle's defense because it's Kyle
Shanahan gonna go because every time I
look at a San Francisco game and I see
one of their running backs they all look
like all-stars I think they all look
like Pro Bowl they've run the ball and
everybody look for that everybody right
every time I look up they're getting the
edge yeah but what do you think
Seattle's defense against San Francisco
or Jacksonville against Indy I mean all
the numbers say Seattle do they all the
numbers say Seattle at home against San
Francisco or
the Indianapolis Colts against the
Jaguars defense that got beat by him a
few weeks ago and maybe no Jalen Rams
yeah I know I guess I would go Seattle
too but you're still worried about it I
I go I worry about them on the run game
I really do yeah I worry about the run
game and then of course like you're
talking about with all the scheme stuff
the bootlegs I'm play action become so
big after that once he can run the ball
on my channel and make those I don't
know not consistently know he's gonna
screw it up how the Seattle defend tight
ends how does Seattle define George
Kittel to me is that yeah well it's
gonna be an issue
it'll be an issue because of what he's
gonna do to them to stress them in the
run game it's gonna put them in a tough
spot yeah I would think Kittel has a
good day I really would but um yeah I
just
I'm with the I think your thoughts
respond I think he's still gotta go
Seattle I don't know I'm with you I just
don't know if we can trust I don't trust
Jacksonville and how do you think of
Kyle Shanahan team bounces back from I
think their worst offensive performance
of the year down there and Tampa Bay
only putting up nine yeah I mean I would
expect it to bounce back I mean I really
would they ran the ball goes I seek
again we know that yeah they did but I
mean I think Breda had like a hundred
and twenty something yards breed is
pretty special man he's he is definitely
a starting running back in the NFL let
me just see really quick last week net
yards rushing a hundred and forty eight
against Tampa there you know how many
rushes was it wasn't even a lot either
was it as like 15 17 24 24 but they
averaged over six yards of carry yeah so
Tampa Bay
yeah so I don't know man you're in a
tough one there you really are that's a
tough one I'm happy with either yeah
probably gonna go Seattle though yeah
the home and the quarterback issue yeah
yeah you made your pick right you'll be
more mad at yourself if you go the other
way you're gonna be mad and I go I go of
course Andrew Luck threw three touchdown
exactly like if San Francisco nicknames
a good guy you're like okay damn I
didn't know who saw that coming exactly
yeah I think that's the logic did you
see we did unfortunately did you see my
brain completely collapse when the words
that came out of your mouth did not
match the spreadsheet I was watching you
I got no video I'm literally talking
going looking at it and going what next
game for 25 the Minnesota Vikings six
four and one
on the road visiting nice Niners homers
and give Kyle the chance every week I
mean I don't have I picked it with them
a lot I don't even know week 12 let's
see I can tell you real quick
week 12 Sims we both came over Tampa
that's obvious 11 week 11 they were on a
bye week soaping week 10 Monday night
against the Giants Sims bet on them yeah
but we got that right you bet the Giants
oh I got that right you got it wrong
yeah right now that you've bailed the
Niners every week that was close
week 9 you both took Oakland and you
were wrong that was the Thursday night
game whatever woke up Mullins
I think I'm wrong on the 49ers every
week week eight you bet on San Francisco
minus one against Arizona
then they week seven Sims you ain't plus
9 and a half you both took them plus
nine and a half against the Rams got
that wrong cuz they got blown out at
home week 6 against Green Bay you took
them plus nine and a half got that right
you both hit it out yeah week five let's
see the one time you bet against that
was Nick Mullens week five you both bet
him Arizona plus four and you hit that
one all right
San Francisco was a favorite that game
yeah let's see week four Sims you took
the Chargers left go cook San Francisco
and you got a right Wow alright so not
every week not really
okay next game here the six born one
Minnesota Vikings on the road visiting
the eight and three New England Patriots
spread in this game is now I'm in week
four let's go back to week Patriots
weather in Foxborough on Sunday 54 and
rainy Chris 54 and rainy okay perfect
perfect New England weather
alright so Savior Rhodes is banged up
with a hammy right digs and feeling are
kind of limited in practice with a knee
and a calf respective I know they said
it's a really mild strain right of the
hammy of Xavier roads I mean still
that's just that's a tough one that's
what I'm say it's your number one corner
and he's limping around off the field
and people are taking slow-mo pictures
of his hamstring tightness yeah you know
those guys tend to usually over
exaggerate those type of he also got
beat on a play there yeah example
response he did
he did he got beat on the pass
interference early in the game - I love
but the only thing is okay so
Patriots offense first Vikings defense I
mean that's that's the showdown right
there that should be awesome
the Vikings defense matches up
personnel-wise about as good as you can
possibly match up against the New
England Patriots just as far as athletic
linebackers and tries to cover Gronk
exactly right Santa Rosa go on Josh
Gordon if he's healthy that will be a
stinker if he can't play because that
would be nice to see that matchup but
you're exactly right never run away from
Trey Wayne nope the run defense for the
Jacksonville Jack I mean at the
Jacksonville Jaguars for the Minnesota
Vikings I mean the Minnesota Vikings
defense is it's really good and we
talked about it a little top down our
Thursday attic it really is and their
defensive line has more depth and is a
better quality defensive line than
they've had in years past so I think
that's impressive the big thing though
for the Vikings on that side of the ball
is one thing to me can Mike Zimmer
change it up can he change it up that
will be big do you see the three guys
and the right I felt the way you thought
about Green Bay's offense so nice
wrinkle yeah I need like 30 more exactly
so he's got out he's gonna have to do
more if he thinks he's just gonna line
up in two or three defenses all day long
against the New England Patriots it's
going to be tough sledding they're gonna
find ways to crack the code I will say
this I don't think the Vikings are gonna
stop the Patriots run game I think the
Patriots will run for over a hundred
yards they will have a hundred yard
rusher in the game I think that's how
good the run game is I'm just gonna say
that right now now the other side of the
ball it goes right back to that right
there
okay can the Vikings run the ball on the
New England Patriots I don't know what
you say to though that left Kel I gotta
see it to believe it
I'm not buying into it and out of the
fact where we've been saying for a while
this is not like the most complex
passing offense we've seen in football
of the Minnesota Vikings when you can't
run the ball and then your offense isn't
real complex and you get into some
obvious passing situations advantage
Bill Belichick and Brian Flores okay
okay okay so I worry about that and yeah
I just think that the
they'll become one-dimensional thought
the Patriots are gonna be all over some
of their past game design out of the
fact in big situations hey Steph Gilmore
will be a handful for either one of
these receivers man demands depth on
Gilmore we don't talk about him cuz he's
a New England robot but he's one of the
best corners in football and nobody
lives on an island as much as he does or
at least he's he's up there but anybody
in the sport I am going $100 on the
Minnesota Vikings yeah 27:23 Patriots
interesting so the only time that Zimmer
has faced Bill Belichick as coach of the
Vikings was 2013 his first year there
Patriots won that game 32 7 Kirk Cousins
has only played one game in New England
at all it was with Washington in 2015
and he lost 27 to 10 one touchdown one
interception to 217 yards I see this as
the cordarrelle Patterson revenge game
this new thing two touchdowns for
cordarrelle Patterson Belichick walks
over to me goes that probably felt good
I have the Patriots winning this game 27
to 20 the don't get that field goal at
the end and I have a hundred and fifty
dollars on the Patriots in this game
[Music]
makes you know fifty or a hundred you
know what band I love more fast in
Boston it's more than a feeling yeah I
look at this and it came down to every
week you tell me that the Minnesota
Vikings are very simple in their attack
yeah and every week I go man if they
could play a defensive coordinator that
could figure it out kind of like Vic
Fangio did now Vic Fangio s defense is a
lot better but also when I look at the
Vikings the reason I bet so much on him
last week against the Packers and I felt
confident is they're a different team at
home sure thirteen that could have beat
the Saints at home they're a team that
crushed the Packers at home but on the
road man they look bad against the Bears
they it was all Kirk Cousins when they
went to the New York Jets
they weren't that great against the
Eagles right I just think New England
matches up really well with them and I
think in the end New England's gonna be
able to diagnose the issues with the
Vikings defense and then find a way to
get it done so I have it 27 20 and if I
can get New England at home in a prime
time type of atmosphere I'm oh it's not
8 o'clock it's 425 I'm time Kirk Cousins
will be ready to go cuz it's not prime
time everybody I just I look at New
England and come on man
it's Patriots time it's time to put your
money where the Patriots are I'm not
Maddie all right guys Sunday Night
Football what a me because it's gonna be
a $250 swing right there Sunday Night
Football the eight and three Los Angeles
chargers on the road visiting the seven
three and one Pittsburgh Steeler spread
in this game is Pittsburgh - three and a
half Chris yup I think the first thing I
start with just as the Chargers defense
versus the Pittsburgh offense it's not a
very good matchup from
for my liking for the Chargers on their
defense okay this is I don't think I'm
just trying to roundabout way this is
the one of the most balanced offenses
they've played this year I'll just put
it into that category you know of course
they're not maybe the Chiefs and Rams
that are explosive ability I understand
that but this is still an extremely
explosive offense that is capable of
running the football I mean it's not the
best running attack we've seen but we
know they can do it and I look at the
Chargers too and just hey there's
there's they're not the biggest team in
the world and the interior part of their
own line the the Steelers I didn't say
this to you let yesterday left go but
the one thing the Steelers need to do
more is they got a stopper on an inside
zone all the time they need to start
pulling DeCastro again and getting into
that game a little bit more the best
pulling car the NFL only one of them yes
I think Andrus peat is taking that title
now okay but either way yes you're he's
extremely good at that and I think
they've been doing too much inside zone
but either way the Chargers gonna have
to respect that run game the other thing
that I look at the Chargers everyone's
going well what about the program and I
understand the program and they're
awesome and I'm freaking fans of both of
them but man Pittsburgh I mean they're
in the discussion for the best pass
protecting a line and all a football you
got him at number two I mean they're
amazing I mean it doesn't matter
Jacksonville Denver last week I mean you
didn't really hear von Miller's name
called last week or Bradley Chubb I
think Vaughn ended up getting a sack but
it was a coverage sacks I mean Ben had
some plays where he pumped faked against
Jacksonville and the Denver Broncos like
four times before he threw the ball how
about this yeah the number one team in
sacks per pass attempt is Indy number
two New Orleans
number three Pittsburgh number four New
England
number five Baltimore yeah and I would
say those are five of your top offensive
lines it's one of my favorite stats yeah
and there you go Pittsburgh number three
Ben always has time where do you look at
that's that and I fell Jesus I'll just
show it to you later oh cool should
teach me something you have to get to
this really complicated looking at
that one right okay all right so that's
all I do is I just take a daddy cigar at
a look at step the chargers offense now
you know you and I both think very
highly of them they could do everything
no Melvin Gordon no Melvin Gordon
hecklers good he is good he's is he's
every bit as good in the past game
they're not gonna miss anything from
that aspect it's the between the tackles
tough running where they're gonna hurt
miss Melvin Gordon I think the charges
will move the ball all over the field on
the Steelers too I really do I just look
at it like this it's in Pittsburgh okay
Pittsburgh's gonna be a little pissed
off with the way they played last week
little and I just have a little more
faith in Pittsburgh getting one or two
more stops than the Chargers on they're
on the defensive side of the ball I'm
actually okay betting with the Chargers
here right hundred dollars on the
Chargers there you go they cover but I
got the Steelers winning 32 27 Ivy I
stayed very strict to my point spreads
this week I'm getting back to basics
Steelers have begun to become a force at
home their last three home games they've
won by 31 15 and 24 they're getting nice
and settled no Melvin Gordon and the
motivation for each team couldn't be
different the Chargers steamroll the
Cardinals high-fiving each other maybe
sharing a daiquiri out there in LA
really enjoying the old strawberry
banana flavor Steelers lose a winnable
game on the road angry Mike Tomlin
nobody's gonna rebound after a loss
better than angry Mike Tomlin and you
know what time this is being played
Chris Sims
[Music]
primetime hopeful Rivers doesn't wilt
under the lights because he has because
in his last 10 games at night in the
primetime Chargers are 2 & 8
oh no in their last 13 prime time games
the Steelers 12 and 100 yeah Steelers
win this game 31 to 23 and I got $100 on
the Pittsburgh Steelers clang clang
clang Steelers there may be a tariffs on
steel but these Pittsburgh is gonna be
worth the cost of admission that means
that our - two of our biggest
disagreements of the week are 425 and
primetime on Sunday night don't steal my
bit the Patriots Vikings Patriots and
that's actually my bed all right Monday
Night Football
Washington six and five on the road
visiting the five and six Philadelphia
Eagles spread in this game is
Philadelphia minus six and a half
weather in Philly on Monday night is
going to be let's go it is gonna be 62
degrees and rainy in the morning but
cloudy after that rainy and the moaning
cloudy after that seems where you going
with the Eagles in the oh by the way can
I show you guys something just posted on
NFL 13 hours ago check up the mustache
on Aaron Rodgers oh my gosh if that
doesn't say we're going on a five-game
winning streak I don't know what does
that's nice well I could hold on to that
and feel safe uh what does he look like
there is it Luigi who that is he look
like he does look like Luigi right Mario
why don't you give me any respect what
is Luigi say I don't know
he doesn't talk it's me Luigi oh when do
I get to take a princess on a date it's
me and told again on a Friday night all
right
no rain in Philly on Monday okay it's
going to tube come out of tube jump out
to flag what are we doing Mario it
really is intriguing that we don't know
what Luigi's voice is very I'm we need
to do it let me look it up
do a deep dive into that okay because I
think I'm nailing Luigi's what I just
don't know what he says well yeah I mean
you're just going with high-pitched
Italian voice and just saying you're
nailing it luigi are you keep talking
all right here we go so questions are so
funny
Redskins Eagles okay first thing is
skins D I do think we'll be all over the
Eagles Pass game concepts you know that
we've talked about this a lot lately
the Eagles Pass game it needs more ideas
and schematics it really does right now
I just look at it it's too much of just
Carson Wentz standing in there making
big time he roles as ours really yeah
okay okay back to you all right so the
fact that there's a Luigi soundboard
readily accessible the Internet is it
just tells you about the Internet the
good though should I do think will be
all over the past game of the
Philadelphia Eagles Eagles showed a
little ability to run the ball last week
okay that's great we'll see if Josh
Adams can continue that but you know
it's a pretty good front for four for
the Washington Redskins I don't think
they're just gonna steamroll that bunch
now the other thing is the Redskins did
a pretty good job pass protecting last
week against the Dallas Cowboys better
than I would have expected to them it
was some of the injury issues they've
had a deal with so I look at that and go
you know what they're gonna be able to
protect Colt enough to where he's not
gonna be just under constant duress and
they should be able to take advantage of
some moments in the passing game against
this Philadelphia the Eagles secondary I
mean Jay Gruden and the Redskins offense
it's not like the most complex thing
I've ever seen but it's good it's got
everything you need as far as to be
successful so I think because of that I
do think the paths the the skins pass
game can do damage okay but I'm still
gonna pick the Eagles to win the game
alright so don't comply the thing yet
I'm
a hundred on the Washington Redskins I
think they keep it close I really do I
think this game is going to be close I
think the only thing that gave me go
okay Washington covers but the Eagles
win as they go the Eagles at home and
I'm really just going on Carson Wentz
that's all I'm doing
Carson Wentz is going ability to I think
just stand in there even though there
won't be a ton open he's so amazing as
standing in there and making big time
throws that I think he'll just be able
to do that a few times I think they win
the game 24 21 mm when I looked at all
of the spreads this week there really
weren't many that made me go that
doesn't make sense right there was a lot
of spreads that I looked at and went
that's a little bit too high right I
don't want to touch the Chiefs too much
- 15 Green Bay at 14 it's it's just so
high that I'm not gonna put a lot of
money on it and then I saw Washington
plus six-and-a-half against the Eagles
and I thought in what world are the
Eagle six and a half point favorites
over anybody it's as though they watched
Washington Dallas saw Zeke run and dak
run and went man Washington stinks with
Colt McCoy yeah I have the Eagles
winning this game 23 to 19 right that's
a Washington cover and I'm putting a
hundred and fifty dollars on Washington
one of my bigger bets because this is a
three-point Eagles win this is a
two-point Eagles win I do not see the
Eagles running away with anything it's
as though they didn't watch the first
half of Eagles Giants and all they did
it was go I mean the Washington defense
is so much better than the Giants
defense it's not even close but they had
to place where a Morrie Cooper ran for
nearly 200 yards combined name one guy
on the Eagles offense that can do that
against Washington there's not a single
guy on the Eagles offense that can
outrun anybody on the Washington defense
no I mean I think Josh Adams gonna be
the fastest guy on your offense right
now and even ham I'm like whatever
right so I I'm not saying that the
Washington Redskins are going to win
this game because I think it means more
to the Eagles but I think 10 days for
Colt McCoy or two Eagles I'm not trying
to be a jerk I'm just going I'm asking
you because all right the main reasons
because it's the same core and I think
Washington's looking at Colt McCoy and
being like I hope this guy can read
whereas the Eagles have more pressure on
them that if they don't make the
playoffs that they will be there will be
a disappointment but Washington at least
has a built-in excuse yes well we lost
our quarterback right and I think for
the Eagles being at home - I just think
they end up pulling this game out but I
wanted to pick this game like 23 22 so I
I might make Washington a lock I just
don't like making Washington a lock yeah
I don't like locking against the Eagles
I hear you all right guys that's it you
want to disagreements left car you want
me to walk it through 11 agreements 5
disagreements here are the big
disagreements Sunday at 1 o'clock you
have $100 on Baltimore +1 I have $50 on
Atlanta that's a hundred and $50 swing
next one one o'clock you have $100 on
Denver - 5 I have $50 on Cincinnati plus
5 that's another $150 we're betting on
Hugh Jackson not really liking that one
by me when I say it out loud if you are
taking guns when you say it out loud
then you just go yeah but I knew that
one was crazy that's why I only did 15
you are doing $100 on Arizona to cover
the 14 I am or to get within 14 I am
betting $50 on Green Bay to cover the 14
that is another 150 dollar swing then
you have $100 on Minnesota to stay
within 5 I have a hundred and fifty for
New England to win by more than five
that has a 250 dollar swing and then
lastly you have $100 on the Chargers to
lose by less than three and a half I
have $100 on the Steelers to win by more
than three and a half that is a $200
swing who you locking 150 150
fifty two fifty two hundred if my math
is right that is seven hundred that is
$900 in disagreements and that is the
total gap between us this week sounds
good
if you win those 500 win we're tied up
but if not cuz again I won all five of
the disagreements last right right you
could have to do that this week yeah
which of those by the way are you most
confident in which you least you're
probably most confident in Denver and
are you least confident in Minnesota um
yeah let me see that were the Chargers I
am least
alright so most confident are just the
ones you just mentioned there I think
I'm most confident hmm that's a tough
one there I'm not sure which one I'm
most confident in probably Denver
against intoning I guess so I would say
that's probably the one I don't know
they're all they're all tough they are
all right so here's what I'm thinking of
going for locks yeah I'd like to hear it
I'm gonna do Chicago - four and a half
in New York got you I am definitely
going to do Houston favored by five and
a half hosting Cleveland at you i man I
really want to do New England - five but
I'm tempted because I want to get an
underdog in there to do Buffalo plus
four and a half in Miami right I really
like the four and a half there so I'm
leaning right now to Chicago Buffalo and
Houston which is crazy to have Buffalo
there and then I'm deciding between the
Rams - ten in Detroit which feels like I
have to do right and New England - five
against Minnesota hmm yeah those are two
tough ones hmm I'm gonna think about it
after all right we got one thing left to
do here left cow we do and because Chris
Sims went five and OH last week over the
phone in his home he is now having to do
guaranteed to lose in the studio two
weeks ago you said I want a different
theme each week that's right like some
different music and our audio engineer
Nick geo Grande
said you got it pal so put that hat on
backwards and get that graffiti cat out
cuz it's done thats is dropps GTL Anna B
hey yo [ __ ] where we start you know
where we're starting left o we starting
right here in New York City Giants gonna
lose our mother freaking Garen head it's
the Chicago Bears
Khaleel Mac you feel me you deal me you
loose
sorry Giants I like this rap version go
ahead I'm going to guess where you going
next and I think you going with the
Texans gonna win the knock off Baker
Mayfield no no it yes Cleveland I don't
believe Lynn you go 1-2 Houston hostess
Shawn Watson that doesn't rhyme but you
gonna lose anyway see uh heavy hitter if
you got a bad girl you gotta send her I
think that's why you trusted Denver take
the Bengals they go and down you putting
that one in the ground guaranteed to
lose what do you say I say shut up
you're wrong on this one damn this one
your than this one oh man I'm going next
to it I I know are you going where huh
to the Big D Detroit yeah tell about
Troy yeah can't mess with em Rams coming
up that vibe too much talent on the
field
say bye-bye Detroit huh I'm gonna Bob we
go to fly hours hood Cardinals come to
town and Aaron Rodgers put them day yeah
you're going down that's right Arizona
you're going down it's too cold for a
cardinal up there and dream man Terry
Rogers sorry Arizona
you're gonna lose heavy hitter style
hey when I sit on the toilet I do a poo
din everybody knows the Raiders have
brewed it what do you think you know how
to put poo and grew in the same code how
dare you do that Vladimir but you're
right I'm big in the Raiders to lose are
you freaking kidding me
this is one of the easiest picks of the
week I guarantee they lose by this one
it's just weather do they lose by 10 or
do they lose by 20 I don't know
but they are going to lose heavy hitters
I wasn't exact on that I liked it Nicky
Jay alright so your five teams guarantee
that our language Josh Giants Cleveland
Detroit Arizona and Oakland I'm laughing
about the moment about halfway through
the Detroit pick we realized that you
couldn't wrap it all and no rhymes for
coming out I mean I always knew I
couldn't rather then you just threw in
the towel and just exactly the hell with
it and then left go right not like
b-rabbit there for a second though left
go rhymed Gruden with putin yes
is that and here we are at the end of
the podcast yes we're here all right
awesome well good luck to you this week
not good luck to you are you gonna be on
television I am which they call it NBC
so pregame show that's what they do your
for and out for know and you're picking
Chargers Pittsburgh so you're gonna pick
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh I just got to pick
the winner right could he go five and
out yes we Florio's face I want your ass
this weekend okay
forceps peace out homies for Fenric good
evening everybody
and the lef koe will lose man holla
holla holla holla holla holla holla
enjoy the games everybody going down
let's go